[Music]  [Music]  the dream  it was clearer than a memory  [Music]  [Music]  and all the dragons roared as one  they consider the matter urgent that of  your succession  who else would have a claim the  firstborn child  brenera no queen has ever sat the iron  throne  the king has an heir damon targaryen  i will not be made to choose between my  brother and my daughter  [Music]  succession will be challenged  knives will come out  [Music]  you are the king  your duty is to take a new wife  i have decided to name a new heir i'm  your hair  is a foot  do you think the ground will ever accept  me as that queen a woman would not  inherit the iron throne because that is  the order of things when i'm queen i  will create a new order  your family has dragons  there are power men should never have  trifled  she will block my way  our hearts remain as one  our hearts are never one  you never imagined yourself  [Music]  sacrifice  [Music]  you